you're listening to the dirty truth with
suzanne mushin and rachel bellow
america's bravest business duo
welcome back to the dirty truth i'm
suzanne and i'm here with rachel who's
my best friend and business partner and
we've been entrepreneurs for over 20
years and we're here to help you change
your life by getting you on the right
path
owning your own
ideas and not working for the man
this show is all about what it takes to
actually be an entrepreneur and in this
segment we introduce you to an
entrepreneur who's really doing all that
because it's one thing for us to talk to
you about it it's another thing for you
to hear firsthand from people actually
doing this so we're talking to evan
carmichael he's got a great story to
tell his website is evancarmichael.com
evan welcome to the show i know this is
a dream come true for you
america's bravest business duo i love it
yeah
so and you're gonna discover why we're
brave with you
today most people evan end their
presentations with a thank you we end
ours with you're welcome
i love it
so you've got a great story and what our
listeners really need to know is how did
you go from being a guy who was working
for literally the man
what was it like in that moment when you
made the decision to start off on your
own tell us about that
so it was tough uh my first real
business i had when i was 19 i was in
university and i was trying to figure
out
do i
keep running my business i i started it
with some you know some friends but
it wasn't going anywhere like i was
sucking as an entrepreneur i was making
300 bucks a month
not able to survive like eating beans
for lunch every day
and i got job opportunities with what
would have been a dream scenario for me
it was merrill lynch and mckinsey a
consultant which like a year prior would
have been
i would love to work for these guys
and i when i did the interviews with
them and i you know what i just didn't
put
effort into it i wasn't that interested
in it anymore i wanted to run
my own thing
did you know wait but evan hold on did
you know when you have that instinct
because i think a lot of people have
that instinct of like i'm done with this
but did you know what the thing was that
you actually wanted to do
well i'm confused because you said you
were already doing it you said you were
already doing it and you were doing it
sucky
i didn't have 20 years of corporate
experience i never actually had a really
you know full-time job before starting
my company
but i thought i was going to be a banker
you looked at like when i graduated i
said i was going to be a banker and in
20 years to be the head of a investment
banking company that was my dream
growing up i didn't have an
entrepreneurial
you know family parents anything there's
no support network but when i started
doing this even like a taste it was part
time in university
something felt right like i had to keep
doing this like i felt
i owed it to myself like i could always
go what was your first entrepreneurial
venture what did you actually start out
doing
well i had a ton of like early failures
uh tiny small businesses like selling
baseball cards that kind of stuff the
very first thing i did was i i was five
and i encouraged my three-year-old
sister to drop pictures with me with my
door-to-door selling them and i earned
my first five cents on my neighbor
but the first real business was it was a
biotech software company and i i didn't
know anything about software i didn't
know anything about
biology uh but i came on and was
basically the business guy and helped
turn that off if you can't hold on a
second but if you came on you mean
somebody else had already started this
company and you came on or this was your
idea
no it was not my idea there were two
founders they had they had started the
company on their own two years prior
released a product that that was great
but
they just didn't know how to market
themselves and then are you a sales guy
or an entrepreneur because a salesman is
the guy who sells and makes other
people's ideas
fabulous and an entrepreneur is the guy
well they're not mutually exclusive but
i have that talent i want to know if
evans when you say you you were an
entrepreneur i don't consider you know
coming into somebody else's business and
making it successful you know you did
that somebody who builds a business
it's not just having a product you gotta
build up a business and part of that is
sales part of that's bringing on the
team and part of that's doing the media
yep yep they had a product that was a
good product but they didn't know
anything about building the business
that's what i came in got it how did you
know how to build a business i didn't
and i sucked at it
but i was interested for me and i was
passionate about it and i almost quit
multiple times like
this wasn't oh here's the answers and go
ahead and we were in some success
so how did it change for you so tell us
the moment when things started getting
traction and started to change for you
the moment changed when i i was at my
absolute lowest i i i was crying on the
phone with my partner and told him i
quit like i'm done this is too much
stress and work we're not gonna make it
uh and then the next day i woke up and i
and i realized i'm not the first guy to
try to solve this problem and that was
the challenge i had was i was trying to
do everything myself come with every
idea of myself i realized i'm not the
first guy and so i looked at other
software companies i looked at how bill
gates started microsoft and how intuit
started mac if you got started and i
looked at how they went from zero to one
not how bill gates makes an extra
million dollars now not interesting but
zero to one that's what i wanted to do
and i modeled his strategies and put it
to work for my business and we started
getting traction so so that is what
you're talking about right now is really
what suzanne and i try to do
in these interviews for our listeners
which is we're not so focused on you
know what it all looks like when the
trees are heavy with fruit but the zero
to one moment the problem is that's a
pretty opaque
moment and it's generally covered up and
glorified the minute you hit success so
how did you find out what those people
did zero to one because i have never
seen anything about the zero to one days
the bigger the company is the easier it
is to find but you gotta dig down and it
may be reading somebody's biography or
could be reading profiles of them like
it was hard to dig down to one of my
favorite books is called radicals and
visionaries by this warroa that explains
a lot of these early stories
but you're right there isn't a ton of
information
but again the bigger the person is you
look at bill gates read his biography
you can find out how he got started evan
is this what
evancarmichael.com now does is uncovers
that that content to help entrepreneurs
the source code for those early moments
i like it the source code i might use
that
um
yeah it's it right now is the largest
collection of famous entrepreneurs
stores and profiles online so we've
built it up so it's stories and stories
and profiles and what's the revenue
model of evancarmichael.com
the revenue model right now is uh off of
guides that i sell so helping
entrepreneurs kind of break it down a to
z of all the major challenges those are
the worksheets that i saw online those
worksheets yeah the worksheets
uh and then i partner up with brands and
i do a lot of work with them helping
them reach the entrepreneurial market
so why do what brands want to reach the
entrepreneur market
puns i work with twitter i work with
dell i work with google i work with hp i
work with home depot
um
and you say you work with them what's
your job when you're working with them
uh usually it's creating content for
them there may be some consulting work
although i hate doing consulting because
it's just time for money but totally
yeah yeah i understand but it's usually
so like i just did a dell twitter chat
so dell is trying to reach out to the
entrepreneur market it's all value-added
they're not selling anything but they're
trying to be seen as a friend of
entrepreneur so so the first thing you
did was become a magnetic
force for the entrepreneurial community
right and once you got a following then
you could turn around and sell that to
partners is that how that worked
absolutely although i don't even do any
selling these guys are coming to me
right but i mean you needed to create
that magnetic field otherwise they
wouldn't have so so for if you're
listening out there the the key is what
community do you want to surround
yourself with and what kind of
compelling content are you going to
create that's going to get you the
numbers that then bring in the big boys
that that sounds real so what evan's
uncovered is a couple of things one is
he went right to his source code he went
right to his passion to figure out what
it was he wanted to do so that he could
do it 24 7 without getting tired because
that's a sign that you're headed in the
right direction you don't get tired you
don't get bored and the other thing that
he did is he figured out to rachel's
point his market
he knew exactly who he wanted to talk to
and then it becomes a whole lot easier
to have a voice in that market and evan
are you are you doing how-to for those
people are you giving them literally
that you know how to on the tools for
being entrepreneurs or what are you
teaching them
at a basic level it's a mix it's a mix
some people need the how-tos they need
to step by step and some people just
need
the motivation to keep going
you know yeah i see a lot of that
motivation on the site and i really like
it it can get a little self-help get a
little bit easy
but but you know what i can't get cheesy
enough with these guys i know it could
be cheesy but it works it worked for me
and i'm just sharing what worked for me
so a lot of people like it we believe it
that's cool too
all right well it's been great to have
you on the show evan
thank you guys
absolutely good luck with
evancarmichael.com